so ceo's leaders executives i'm talking
to you know a lot of time when we're
running a business and we talk to our
board or we talk to our cfos or we talk
to finance it's always hey what's your
budget how much money do you have to do
this and to do that we're like oh my god
where do i invest my money and what do i
put my money into and the last thing we
think about is what would happen if we
actually invested our resources into our
employees and future leaders for example
one of our guys two of them mario and
secret were going to be
leaders in a marketing department for
two separate companies first thing i
said is listen before you guys do this
let's find the best marketing program
for a week we did it was wharton
business school it was like fifteen
thousand dollars each i sent both of
them to wharton for a week they went
there spending time for one week with
other cmos with other directors of
marketing of largest corp larger
corporations they came back saying never
saw marketing like this before morale
was going to be a chief reputation
officer i sent her to harvard business
school for a week it was another 15 000
program kai
dinkin mario wanted to get better at
funnels we send them to click funnel
conference but we keep investing into
the people that are growing our
companies and if you're a person right
now especially during this recession
market crash that we're going into if
you don't invest into your people the
biggest mistake is you're going to keep
people that are not getting better which
means the value of companies are going
to go higher so we're doing a special uh
discount specifically for those because
many keep asking pat i don't want to
come by myself i want to invest into my
teammates and bring them to the vault if
that's you there's a 20 discount for
anybody that purchases three tickets for
their attendees click on the link above
or below i'll see you and your teammates
in miami at the vault the first week of
september take care everybody bye-bye